merci d'être avec nous bien venu sur
arte france de la culture restaurant
emmanuel macouin laissé entrevoir une
lueur d'espoir mais aucun calendrier des
ouvertures pour d'autres entreprises
citons par exemple les discothèques les
salles des sports
ces entreprises restent dans la tente de
nouvelles annonces
oui bonjour absolument il ya un tas de
secteurs comme les kilos quand vous
disiez les boîtes de nuit et les
discothèques et même les bars de soir
puisqu'on a appris que le couvre-feu
allait continuer ils les salles de sport
bien entendu tout ça on n'a pas de
visibilité et d'ailleurs même pour les
restaurants les musées etc
actuellement on a des débris ddd
annonces sont parfois contre lui
annoncer un jour par le porte parole et
contredit le lendemain modéré par un
ministre donc on est absolument sûrs de
rien encore aujourd'hui et on est
toujours dans l'attenté d'un calendrier
clair fixe précis et dont on est sûr
qu'il sera tenu pour tous les secteurs
alors les premiers 100 débute ce
calendrier qui commence à signer 15 mai
en tout cas pour les terrasses de
restaurants et les musées est ce que
vous y croyez
on a envie de croire du président de la
république et du gouvernement le
problème comme je vous disais c'est
qu'encore une fois nous n'avons rien de
précis d'annoncer officiellement par
écrit avec des dates fixes de
réouverture comme on peut le voir dans
les pays voisins par exemple en
angleterre il aurait ouvert la semaine
dernière il avait la date du ring le 22
février
donc il savait à l'avancé le calendrier
a été tenu le calendrier est tenu en
france on nous dit que c'est toujours
une hypothèse parce que c'est soumis à
la situation sanitaire du pays dans les
semaines à venir
sauf que dans les autres pays ils ont
réussi à faire pourtant ils sont
victimes de la même pandémie pourquoi en
france on n'est pas capable d'avoir des
directives claires fixée précise une
vision précise et certaines parce que là
ça met tout le monde dans l'embarras
sam et les acteurs économiques
dans tendue dans le flou complet tout le
monde et est figé tout le monde est
bloqué et on a beau avoir envie d'y
croire
la confiance est rompue et aujourd'hui
on veut c'est les actes et on y croira
quand on gratte demain pouvait tourner
la clé de votre commerce et rigoler là
on n'y croit pas alors admettons qu'on
ait une ouverture en tout cas un début
de rêve mercure le 15 mai comment
voyez-vous la pré déconfinement pour ces
petites entreprises ce code le plus dur
n'est pas à venir si bien entendu avec
la confédération nationale des tpe on a
le retour des entrepreneurs sur toute la
france on est en est à leur écoute et ce
qu'on entend c'est que ça va être
compliqué parce qu'ils repartent
surendettés et bruno le maire a beau
annoncé envisager de prendre en charge
une partie des dettes
c'est un peu facile dans la mesure où
c'est quand même leur politique de ce
gouvernement la politique sanitaire qui
nous a mis dans cette situation donc oui
il faudra des aides à la reprise parce
que sinon ça va être une catastrophe
n'est pas qu'une catastrophe pour nos
entreprises
sam est une catastrophe pour l'emploi
parce que le premier levier sur lequel
quand on part sur endettés on peut
réduire ses charges fixes
quand on a des têtes en plus à payer
mais le premier league et ça va être de
se séparer d'un salarié ou de réduire le
nombre de salariés d'ailleurs la
réouverture des terrasses ne permettra
pas de rembaucher tout le monde puisque
tout le monde n'a pas de terrasse et
même ceux qui en ont ils vont travailler
parfois qu'à 25 % de leur capacité
quand c'est pas moins donc ça ne
résoudra pas le problème et le fait que
le couvre-feu continue à une date qu'on
connaît pas puisque c'est toujours
pareil on n'a pas de calendrier on n'a
pas de directives claires on sait pas
quand tout ça s'arrêtera on connaît même
pas d'ailleurs les critères qui
permettront de rentrer et de sortir en
restriction à ça fait un an qu'on subit
ces restrictions n'a toujours pas de
réponse sur les critères qui nous
pouvons rentrer en restriction en tel
clip de restriction en sortir de tel
type de restrictions donc ça va être
très compliqué et il va falloir que les
accompagnements continue pour sauver
l'emploi et pour sauver les petites
entreprises actuellement
l'accompagnement les aides financières
de l'état sont elles
suffisantes elles sont suffisantes pour
une partie des entrepreneurs il ya des
trous dans la tête qui ont été comblés
mais il en reste quand même un certain
nombre avec le collectif sos est
acharnée en détresse avec mon travail on
représente masse considérable
d'entrepreneurs notamment dans
l'hôtellerie restauration discothèques
etc
et je peux vous dire qu'il ya beaucoup
de cafouillage sur le fond de solidarité
il y en a qui y ont leurs fonds de
solidarité bloqué depuis des mois sans
avoir d'explication valable c'est très
compliqué pour certains qui sont soit
déjà en faillite soit au bord de la
faillite parce qu'ils n'ont pas touché
les aides on sait pas trop pourquoi
et puis il ya aussi des promesses qui
attendent toujours des réponses on
entend des promesses sur les plateaux
télé notamment par rapport aux
repreneurs de 2021
tous ceux qui ont repris une entreprise
après le 1er janvier 2021 eux ne sont
toujours pas aidé par le gouvernement
par les aides
il n'y a toujours pas d'ailleurs c'est
pas des aides c'est des indemnités
compensant le lot fermeture obligatoire
parce que nous on n'a rien demandé
dans l'absolu on préférait tout ce
travail et donc c'est pas des aides
c'est les indemnisations
sauf qu'il ya des gens qui malgré le
fait qu'ils doivent payer des charges
fixes nous n'ont toujours pas
d'indemnisation
donc oui adn ça suffit à certains et
heureusement qu'elles sont là mais c'est
encore insuffisant pour remplir les
trous qui a dans la raquette des aides
et il ya des réponses des questions qui
restent sans réponse à ce jour
et en plus on se demande jusqu'à quand
ils vont pouvoir financer tout ça parce
qu'au bout d'un moment
s'il n'y a pas de vision claire à long
terme il sera évident que tout ça ça va
être un jour et on a bien entendu le
message du ministre de l'économie qui a
dit que les entreprises qui bénéficient
des indemnisations aujourd'hui devront
en supporter le remboursement demain et
on suppose que ce sera pas les plus
grosses entreprises qui en supporteront
le remboursement
donc on s'attend au pire dans les mois
et dans les années qui viennent sera
très compliqué
garrard du no merci à vous merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes fondateur du collectif en très
très peu
et porte parole de la confédération
nationale des tpe en gironde merci à
vous